three two one ignition and liftoff NASA
launched Juno on August 5th 2011 on July
4th 2016 it will become the first
spacecraft to peer under the clouds of
Jupiter's massive surface it has already
made the farthest solar-powered trip in
the history of space exploration made
even more impressive by the fact that in
Jupiter's orbit it receives only 4
percent the amount of sunlight we have
here on earth which amounts to only 486
watts of power the equivalent of about
eight standard household light bulbs and
once it nears Jupiter's surface that
will drop to around 420 watts
due to radiation degradation the
radiation exposure during the course of
the Jupiter orbit will be nearly 60
million times that of Earth's atmosphere
needless to say not many man-made things
have endured anything near the
punishment that Juno will over the
course of its mission but after five
years of traveling it will reach its
destination by looking deep into
Jupiter's atmosphere to measure the
plants composition and climate track
it's cloud motions and map both the
magnetic and gravity fields Juno will
not only provide spectacular
never-before-seen images but
unprecedented insight into the formation
of our solar system